une vidéo sur breath of the wild 2 alors
qu'on n'a aucune info bah ouais j'ai
envie de me faire plaisir et de me
replonger dans cet univers phénoménal
bon il est vrai je vous avais déjà parlé
des mystères autour de ce jeu de cette
suite dans un 3 théorie mais il existe
encore bien des secrets des mystères
autour de cet opus même avec une simple
annonce je ne vais pas vous représenter
le trailer ni l'analyse est de nouveau
je pense que vous l'avez tous en mémoire
et de toute façon va pas faire de
l'analyse image par image mais
simplement réfléchir et penser ensemble
bien on y va déjà il faut se référer aux
premiers breath of the wild nintendo
pour concevoir leur jeu se base toujours
et beaucoup sur les nouvelles
fonctionnalités apportées par leur
console par exemple dans pokémon ep
bouclier le giga max ce n'est pas par
désir de scénario ou delorme est juste
car on peut jouer à pokémon sur grand
écran
donc on va créer des big pokémon tout
simplement fawi désolé et badens zelda
c'est à peu près pareil comme dans
skyward sword où on lève les paies vers
le ciel c'est juste pour la motion
capture via le wii motion plus si vous
vous souvenez donc voilà je vous ai mis
le contexte s'est parée pour breath of
the wild au lancement de la switch avec
la création d'un grand monde ouvert et
la liberté de jouer où on veut et quand
on veut vous vous doutez bien que ce
sera également le cas pour breath of the
wild 2 le premier opus était axée sur la
découverte link est mort suite à son
combat face à la calamité ganon dans un
reer hull riche et glorieux on le
retrouve donc après une absence de cent
années
tant qu'il lui a fallu pour ce
ressuscité entre guillemets link a été
absent pendant 100 ans
et en plus il a perdu la mémoire tout ça
ce sont des facilités scénaristiques
pour nous permettre de découvrir le
monde d'hyrule de façon cohérente link
n'est plus dans la même époque ne se
souvient plus de rien on va redécouvrir
grâce à lui la main
et bien c'est là le point pertinent pour
moi pour deviner ce qu'il va se passer
dans breath of the wild 2 il faut penser
gameplay game design et non scénario car
justement ce sont ces éléments qui vont
pouvoir justifier le scénario pour
conclure cette partie breath of the way
nous montrer un monde dévasté où link
était le dernier espoir cela crée une
atmosphère particulière aux jeux avec
peu d'habitants des morts etc
l'idée pertinente pour moi concernant ce
second opus serait en gros la
reconstruction du monde une autre
thématique un peu al'inverse du premier
jeu ganon et maintenant vaincu la paix
de retour sur le monde ce serait donc
une toute nouvelle atmosphère mais
surtout si on pense en termes gameplay
et d'innovation on connaît maintenant la
map de breath of the wild
on a tous passé des heures et des heures
à parcourir les plaines d'hyrule les
montagnes goron le domaine aura piaf et
cetera gros respect à ceux qui ont fait
les 900 noah coraux moi je suis resté
bloqué à 897 mais voilà c'est ça le truc
maintenant on connaît hyrule il est tout
à fait impensable que nintendo nous
propose exactement la même map que
breath of the wild 1 ce serait se tirer
une balle dans le pied
autant de sortir un simple dlc dans ce
cas c'est pour ça que je parlais de la
reconstruction d'hyrule et son
amélioration
l'idée de ne plus jamais reproduire les
erreurs du passé et rebâtir suite au
carnage et le traumatisme qu'a créé
calamité ganon enfin voilà la map sera
forcément modifié mais comment justifier
ça pour moi alerte subjectif soit breath
of the wild 2 nous propose une grosse
ellipses zelda a eu le temps de se
couper les veines après le confinement
puis les survivants ont rebâti ce qui a
été détruit sous les ordres de linkey la
princesse bref soit nous retournons dans
le passé pour avoir le hyrule glorieux
de l'époque et du coup mieux comprendre
le carnage d'il ya cent ans ou bien une
réalité parallèle comme lo rulh ou
termina avec donc une map bien
différente
c'est d'ailleurs très à la mode ces
dernières années le voyage dans le temps
et les
alité parallèle bon il est temps que
nous passions à gagner' le point
pertinent et que le mal revient et
réapparaît toujours est normalement
ganon ou ganondorf mais plusieurs années
et même quasiment une génération entière
avant de revenir sauf qu'ici nous avons
toujours les mêmes lda et lync et ils
sont encore très jeunes même alors je le
conçois il ya quasi 100% de chances que
calamité ganon soit une sorte de
projection comme je vous en parlais dans
mon trois théories une sorte d'ouverture
dans le saut qui lui a permis de revenir
via cette projection pour se libérer
néanmoins ça les héros ne le savent pas
est techniquement la créature qui est
sûrement ganondorf bas elle est toujours
celles et ceux qui veut dire qu'il n'y a
donc plus de mal sur hyrule et on y vit
des jours heureux et là où c'est encore
plus pertinents c'est que ce sont celles
d' high link qui vont dans les tréfonds
du château pour réveiller le mal par
inadvertance dans un zelda classique le
scénario se forment et se créent dû à
l'apparition du mal comme ganondorf etc
car justement ils veulent dominer le
monde et tout ralala les méchants ce
sont des éléments perturbateurs en gros
lda et link vivent leur vie
puis le scénario arrive car le mal se
réveille prend le pouvoir s'imposer tu
sais je sais pas si vous me suivez
parfaitement
sauf qu'ici dans la conception du
trailer est ce qui nous est montré
c'est bel et bien un zelda et link qui
se dirige vers le mâle et ceci apportera
nécessairement des petites modifications
au scénario de base que possèdent les
zelda mais du coup si on réfléchit un
peu
dans quel but vont-ils réveiller le mal
pour moi soit c'est une simple erreur
zelda est à moitié archéologues dans le
premier opus alors ils savaient pas ils
ont appuyé sur un truc et puis boum
tiens c'est quoi ce bouton soit c'est
prémédité
ils ont connaissance de la véritable
source de calamity ganon et du coup ils
vont voir après comment ils ont su que
c'était la source ça c'est encore une
autre histoire soit et c'est là où c'est
intéressant ils ont connaissance du
cycle éternel et il souhaite le briser
mais cela implique du coup énormément de
choses effectivement si l'on
connaissance du fameux cycle éternel
cela veut dire que je prends en compte
skyward sword et donc de la timeline
zelda et on ne sait toujours pas si
c'est ce que veut réellement nintendo
par le biais de la nouvelle console
nintendo la switch et les nouveautés
apportées par breath of the wild
il est à parier que nintendo souhaite
instaurer quelque chose de nouveau et
enfin se séparer de la timeline qui
l'aura vraiment bien casser les cojones
ces dernières années je ne vous apprends
rien la timeline est une création des
fans puis vu que tout le monde se hype
et autour de sa nintendo a joué là
dessus mais ça a pris trop d'ampleur
et cela n'a jamais été ce qui était
prévu à la base donc aujourd'hui ça leur
casse les couilles
oui je le dis mais bon c'est impossible
de savoir encore pour le moment tant
qu'on n'a pas le jeu entre les mains
à voir si la timeline sera prise en
considération contrairement au premier
opus je vous invite néanmoins à revoir
mon trois théories sur le trailer car au
final bas il est toujours autant
d'actualité
en même temps s'il ya eu aucune nouvelle
info c'est un peu normal
néanmoins la timeline le lors de zelda
cela repose beaucoup sur le personnage
de ganondorf et de son retour bah oui
des miles est à l'origine du problème et
et de ce fameux cycle éternel ou une
représentation de sa haine renaît à
chaque fois et où les élus des déesses
renaîtront pour l'affronter c'est pour
ça que breath of the white 2 est
intrigant car il semble signer leur
retour de cette antagonistes mythique
avoir le retour d'un ganondorf sous
forme humaine implique forcément une
histoire derrière tout ça une
intelligence et c'est ce que je veux
dire c'est que ganon n'est qu'une bête
féroce en soit on ne va pas dialoguer
avec le retour de ganondorf sous forme
humaine est un choix contradictoire avec
l'objectif de se séparer de la timeline
est moins cela m'intrigue beaucoup
est il possible que breath of the wild 2
soit ici pour justement briser cette
timeline à tout jamais afin d'avoir de
nouvelles bases saines je vous le mets
en 1011 sera ma conclusion ganondorf se
réveille suite à l'exploration de link
et zelda dans les souterrains du château
ce dernier est une momie donc qui dit
mot me dit core faible qui dit core
faibles dit la recherche d'un nouveau
corps ou la récupération de ses pouvoirs
et là la théorie du voyage dans le temps
peut faire mouche
déjà c'est très moderne et c'est très
21e siècle vu le nombre d'oeuvres de la
pop culture qui traite de cet aspect ces
dernières années bref le voyage dans le
temps cela permet de rester dans hyrule
mais d'avoir une nouvelle map avec des
créatures divines devrait bâtisse et non
des ruines une population affluentes etc
en gros du nouveau dans du vieux quoi
cela permettrait de mettre en lumière
des zones d'ombré du scénario expliqué
en deux cinématiques de trois minutes
donc ajouter du l'or est plus de
cohérence à l'univers cela permettrait
aussi de justifier l'histoire de cette
momie ganondorf ce qu'il fait là et
c'est donc la recherche potentielle d'un
nouveau corps ou de la récupération de
ses pouvoirs mais évidemment il ya un
mais cela créerait une boucle temporelle
dans l'histoire dans le sens où ce
serait link du présent qui en fait
aurait scellé ganondorf dans le passé
qui serait revenue dix mille ans plus
tard etc
et moi je vous le dit les créatures
divines ce n'est pas un bon by 100% si
elles étaient enterrés ce n'est pas pour
rien car oui retourner dans le passé
nous expliquerait la véritable nature de
ces créatures par exemple bref je
pourrais vous parler des heures et des
heures d'un scénario autour d'une boucle
temporelle
j'avoue que c'est un peu une thématique
qui me passionne chez moi un peu le
temps a vous de me dire ce que vous
aimeriez dans les commentaires mais
surtout le voyage dans le temps
permettrait de la faire à la des poules
pour nintendo la chronologie aller voilà
j'espère que ma vidéo vous aura plu je
n'avais aucune prétention à la faire
j'avais juste vraiment envie de parler
de zelda parce que je kiffe ça donc si
ça vous a plu n'hésitez vraiment pas à
me laisser un gros pouce bleus de
l'amour à me dire si vous voulez qu'on
se refasse des vidéos comme ça sur zelda
ou sur d'autres univers
puis bah voilà et puis bah abonnez-vous
que le lionheart soit avec vous c'était
argot rock
[Musique]
m